what did you expect would happen at
story expo what did did you have certain
notions batter you said I'm coming here
with no yeah I never have expectations
at all when I come to these I started
coming to these you know for Ken to my
first one I used to fly out here and act
like I belong that's kind of how I do
things and I'd walk around la Beverly
Hills like I lived here and there were
pitch fest so I'd go to them so and I
kind of put myself in places that I
think I need to be and things happen so
a lot of my friends say you're crazy man
you're going out there with nothing and
you know but I met contacts and when I
moved out here all my friends already
already you know made my friends in my
contacts oh so but I never really have
expectations when I come to these I just
have conversations about my work do you
think having been in law enforcement you
just felt like it's like you've seen
probably worse than anybody since so
it's like how bad could it be maybe
somebody says all right great yeah you
know it's funny he said I was at a firm
if I don't want to name drop but it's a
huge company and they were getting into
TV they were big on management the music
side when you walk into office and
everybody's there they've managed
everyone anyway the guy calls and my
management says we couldn't even got
anything and so he sends me over and the
guy listened and it was great great
pitch had a good time and then he says
something that really pissed me off he
said ok you know we got you know this
rapper in that rapper and you know I
said why'd you name those guys because
they're tall no it was a short you know
well they're black you know and so he
tried the thing again so I said listen
this is a show like I told you earlier
it's about it's about everyone so by
kids in trouble kids in trouble come in
many flavors he goes well you're going
to regret it if you leave this office
without a deal you gonna regret it so I
said listen man I've seen people on the
street dead I've walked through crime
scenes where the
blow your mind I've seen a kid pick up
an Uzi and spray a neighborhood miles on
patrol this is nothing you know and my
manager tried to stop me you know and
Tom you're gonna you know mess it up and
I said la man I mean look I want to be
in business with someone who wants to be
business with me I won't be in business
with someone who's not mean and nasty
you know I've already dealt with that in
a police world I don't want to deal with
that here so this guy tells me i'll
never work again in Hollywood whatever I
don't you know but I'm not gonna leave
until he hears what I had to say so so
anyway needs to say that didn't work out
but but I made my point
you